[Music]
what we're gonna do right here is go
back one two three
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
by the power of crowder shop
i have the power
dave you're not wearing pants tis true
where'd dave get those cool threads
wouldn't you like to know
it's a mystery but you can start your
treasure hunt at crowdershop.com
i think you'll be pleasantly surprised
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
good
[Music]
speedy
[Music]
hmm
very nice delicious i guess i have a
little moroccan mint
tea today oh which i didn't know is a
thing but i saw babel fancy seriously um
also they had the highest concentration
of jews outside of israel at one point
babel and something about the making the
sicilians black what
what
a little bit more a little more history
for you what the world is there you go
right off the top we have a lot to get
to today look fire tucker carlson or was
it cancelled tucker carlson i can't
probably just both was trending of
course canceling dave ship they what
look people use the term cancel culture
i'm going to talk about this today let's
i've never really liked the term because
it's someone trying to coin it like
magdavers or maga people it's like
you're talking about people who are just
really you know traditional
conservatives who want what's best for
america uh with canceled culture what
we're really talking about with dave
chappelle with tucker carlson is people
don't like them and they want to get
them fired and they want them to lose
their livelihood and people misconstrue
what happens with dave chappelle right
they say see there's no canceled culture
he has a special that's because he's one
of the most prolific comedy writers of
our time the concern is what happens to
people who are not dave chappelle who
are not tucker carlson in the comedy
clubs who are maybe at local networks
who never get on a national platform
that's the issue it's about the barrier
to entry and people sort of misconstrue
that with the folks who are at the top
and even the stuff that dave chappelle
did tucker carlson did
it's really not that bad no no no no no
it's it's case funny it's really not hey
but uh uh let me introduce gerald a uh
how are you
feeling better i am i feel like i missed
the boat though i didn't get to earn my
you know immunity is that an indigenous
people's joke no no oh yeah no i missed
the i know the smallpox blanket ah well
i'll send you one yeah well thank you
very much centuries before germ theory
don't know how that rumor got started
but it's taught in schools we'll get to
that too in a little bit uh because the
fbi doj are going to investigate you
parents if you complain at pta meetings
who'd have thought oh rightfully so yeah
quarter black garrett he
is still around you're a good dad i am
yeah and
a fourth i got a fourth on the way what
announcement uh
thank you thank you i thought you said
clark's down there i thought you closed
up the shop no no no i will be after
this though no yeah i can't i can't dude
that's too many snip snip snip snip
there a really old sword taint i can
just i don't want to talk
i ruined i ruined christmas dinner in
reno where a guy was like i just had a
vasectomy you needed his wife was like
do you need some ice and i said yeah you
need to put need to put a frozen bag of
peas on that taint
and he said it's not my turn it's
actually really shitty i don't care
about them just come on grow up
you're the one that's that tate at
thanksgiving yeah but he's the one who
was offended at it i'm trying to eat
here
yeah well whatever
i never said i was an adult
it's easy for you to say you haven't got
half a dozen pairs of short pants
hanging in your closet name that movie
line people out there and uh dave landau
is here how are you sir ahoy i'm good
i'm great you're gonna be in orlando
this weekend uh yes that's correct this
weekend and he just announced that he's
having a baby so i was also on a fishing
show oh
very nice congrats orlando avoid the
nightclubs yeah i hear well i hear like
to go dancing i hear they're a blast but
you really don't want to take it well i
don't know what i'm gonna do with these
booty shorts and all this ecstasy well
i'm sure we'll find something for it
yeah i bet i will that's a crime uh hey
by the way i don't think if we have this
today is actually national coming out
day hey
uber celebrated
yeah oh uber home can we scroll down
with the uber well
yeah you could have a ride from this
person let it never be said no that
there's any deviance
in that community i think one second a
seat belt it's not a seat you know
what's fun about that person too is that
she was born a woman
transitioned into a male to do drag
so what well you could have just done
that i feel like this is the kind of
crap freud shuffling paper i i don't
have a form for this
he's like i wish you all just still
wanted to bang your mother yeah look
it'd be a little more natural i'm a
little pissed off they didn't lump this
in with july like you've got july take
the whole month and do this but now i
understand they wanted it close to
halloween so they would have an excuse
there's so many gay
days okay and i'm not just
and i'm not just talking about boxing
day in canada where you get a fake
discount there's what they're saying
there's there's a day when i allow
myself things yes yeah well look
reporter went and went in a porta potty
in la yeah there's
bisexual international bisexual day then
there's by visibility day which i'm not
sure then there's uh you know
international gay pride
national coming out day yeah there's so
like it's just with martin luther king
it makes sense martin luther king day
okay honor the man who's the forefather
really or you could argue but certainly
one of the catalysts of the modern civil
rights movement getting done to vote
that's absolutely fantastic great i
understand why it's celebrated let's not
compare that to your preference of
friction or eye makeup uber yeah let's
cancel christmas yeah let's cancel
christmas no by the way i had an uber
driver i don't know if i should tell
this it's a slow news day so yeah uh i
had an uber driver who i got in one time
after a place where we often go i'm
sorry
and i get into the uber and i look i see
all these christmas lights and i see
it's like red velvet everywhere yeah and
i look up front there's fake snow
and the uber driver is santa claus oh
i mean a real
beard and he goes okay i'm taking you to
my address and i say uh yes sir he goes
and don't forget i swear to you goes
this wasn't maybe april there's only 263
more days until christmas young man
oh my god this guy is daniel day-lewis
saying uber and then before i leave he
goes well thank you for the pleasure we
ended up talking i found out that he
goes he does this part-time to go on
cruises with his wife he's retired nice
i love that and uh as i'm leaving he
goes thank you i enjoyed the
conversation
and stephen i hear you've been a very
good boy this year
[Laughter]
it's like i just want to fight and then
i was at home i got to listen
there are articles about him that's
awesome but i want legendary i want him
my only uber by request
long story short died in a horrible
drinking and driving experience oh
no yeah no milking jolly he was dipping
yes he was tipping a little distracted
oh so 18 wheeler yeah
who's reaching back for some carrots for
the reindeer
she's texting i got in a car with a
woman she was driving amazing and i was
like you were the best driver i've ever
seen and she's like yeah i used to be a
boy
oh
dave and then
so we have a lot to talk about today uh
look there's there's
what are they talking about right now a
merc with a pill to treat chronovirus no
that's okay five vermectin i know that's
a joke you can fat check me snopes um
before we move on to this apparently uh
the left on tick tock this is libs on
tick tock yeah sort of
they scrape these things uh have once
again they've canceled another offensive
term but a national is it international
coming out day or is it national i'm
pretty sure it's uh national intergala
national national coming out day well
you know what
the queer should it should be next thing
there's going to be queers without
borders in the middle east it's just a
new day for hunting yeah
they don't celebrate these holidays or
flying yeah that's true okay they gotta
test yourself
they invite you to the rooftop for a
complimentary yoga class yeah all males
that show up and they give you a james
con right off of it this position is
touch your toes it's called shooting
eagle
bye yes goodbye to you
uh so the new word that's being
cancelled now on tick-tock
guys
let's talk about the use of guys as a
gender-neutral term for a lot of trans
binary folks being referred to in this
way triggers their dysphoria and people
will say oh i call all my friends guys
even my girlfriends but your sis friends
did not experience the trauma of being
conditioned into a gender that is not
theirs for me i have stopped saying it
because i realized the importance of
de-gendering our language language
matters and the words that we use inform
the way we see the world i agree it
literally studies on this
doctors lately guys to be gender neutral
and not girls or ladies this fuels the
narrative that man is default and this
is the core of the patriarchy look you
can use whatever words you want you have
to consider their impact and if someone
tells you that the language you are
using i didn't know jennifer connolly
was this investor
for you i think that says a lot about
your character okay a couple of things
by the way i love you i use the term
guys all the time yeah okay and some if
it's in a room and sometimes it includes
women if it's only women i will say gals
or ladies ladies but the idea here is
that because of the trauma of okay look
and we're going to get to the dave
chappelle thing
they always talk about how i know people
who attempted suicide if people are
attempting suicide because of a dave
chappelle special or if people have to
spend thousands of dollars on a
psychiatrist because you walked into a
room with mostly guys and use the term
guys
maybe you're not mentally stable i
understand i understand you can take a
dump at target and not at walmart and
this is as bad as the uh you know the
treatment of chinese internment camps
right from the japanese and it's true
but
look
the suicide rate isn't as high in
american slaves it wasn't as high jews
and the holocaust you can look it up so
if you think that the only reason the
depression the anxiety the mental health
issues the suicide rate is so high
because someone used the term
guys
or maybe it's you it might be you
basically well i think they're coming
after neil armstrong next because when
he landed on the moon he said for all
mankind i mean
man kind right step for me i guess we
just
son of a gun well today would be some
pansexual and booty shorts who takes a
dump and drops a little rainbow flag in
it just
san francisco on the moon yeah fake
beard i think it might be called guy uh
if you have martin scorsese's eyebrows
how about that
good lord the word it's just how you
address people it's not a girl
to other girls hey guys if this is just
such an insane way though to restrict
all language and to be offended by
literally everything hey guys
what i'm supposed to believe that
someone's going to david carradine
themselves because i walked into a room
and said hey buddy
well that was more about blessings that
was yeah it was a pleasure thing
i'm so maybe they will yeah well that's
on uh that's on lift that's a good way
to be found in a thailand closet yeah
hey so my question of the day because
we're going to get this is how scary is
it to that the government is now
targeting parents
with a summer of love we had anthony we
had black lives matter i want to know
are you aware of the doj that they're
going to be targeting and investigating
parents for speaking out at these school
board meetings here's one thing here's
my challenge to anybody
find me i've been looking all morning
i'm not saying that it's incorrect
i make mistakes we're going to issue a
correction later today from a whopper
last week
i have not seen one act of violence from
a parent to a teacher at these meetings
well there's so many
threats
though oh it's deserved but it hasn't
happened yet we'll see about that if
it's just threats then my twitter then
my twitter at reply should be an fbi
house
it's a hate crime stephen all right so i
want to get before that while we're
talking about celebrities here this is
just it was just too deli and i'm not
alanis morissetting this the irony
oh so it's actually irony yeah it's
actually yeah uh
so dave batista for people who don't
remember back in october 2020 he was
showing for biden harris and he was
advocating obviously for big government
on gun control okay so this is him then
where he said my fellow gun owners joe
biden is pro second amendment he wants
gun reform a ban on assault rifles and a
voluntary buyback of assault rifles
owned i won't even get into the fact
that he probably doesn't know what an
assault rifle is he thinks it's a laser
blaster from guardians of the galaxy
this is fair this was save lives i don't
need to overcompensate with an ar-15 a
lawyer your right to bear arms okay
first off here's something let me just
address and we'll get to
we'll get to the point of this because
now he's complaining about something
that he didn't foresee when people say i
don't need to compensate with an ar-15
every guy in a wheelchair has a small
dick
every woman is compensating to avoid
being gang-raped in inglewood california
it's the stupidest art you know who
carries more than ufc champions we've
had them on it we've boss wrote and
talked to us he said everyone wants to
pull up and pull up and test us
he said really in the street of course
i'm not going to fight somebody it's a
liability i'm only going to defend
myself with a firearm you no matter how
tough you are are not tougher than
either multiple attackers or
an attacker with a weapon it's not
compensating right it's not compensating
like taking steroids and going out there
and tell everyone how tough you are it's
especially important for women for
people who may not be able to afford the
the anavar dosage that you do exactly
why would you take one of the most
effective firearms and say no because
it's so effective isn't that the point
yeah i have no choice
that maybe that was them with a vaccine
they had a version like nah it's too
this works too well let's do bird shot
for everybody just so you can piss your
attacker off further yeah exactly you
can feel a burst shot with coins though
i found out in a tom hanks movie really
yeah you killed somebody well don't fire
that in the wrong area of uh hollywood
with all this no
laying around look run
winning
change i'm joking you would do it in the
primarily uh indian area so i had to
register these as lethal weapons well
that was a sex offender yes exactly the
wrong register you also had to uh hold
them up when you notified all your
neighbors that's true but i did bring
them up high with hair in it very nice
okay so this is what's ironic cause
you're saying you can be safe with a
voluntary buyback well he wanted to make
uh uh beto his guns are who said it's a
mandatory gun back like australia but
here's the thing the issue right is once
you give government control look at the
assault weapons ban of 94. it became
nothing but bureaucratic red tape this
was legal pistol grip illegal just
little cosmetic differences to try and
make it hard for a gun manufacturers and
mom and pop shops to be able to provide
you with the means to defend yourself
the main issue is it's an infringement
of our rights but it also creates
another big government bureaucracy who
of course use this power to infringe on
your rights batista didn't see that
coming and now i think this went up just
this weekend he's pissed about
big government red tape and regulations
here's batista now i have a riddle i
have a riddle it's a mystery and i need
help with i can't figure it out how many
bureaucrats does it take
to grant
an awful citizen of tampa like myself he
just called himself an awful citizen i'm
dealing with people who have meetings to
set other meetings i'm dealing with
people who give me a list of stuff to do
just so i can take to them so they can
give me another list of stuff to do
about government spend thousands of
dollars on permits i spent 40 grand last
week on a wire what the [ __ ] do i have
to do to get power from the city of
tampa
well first off you should learn what a
riddle is
um
it's like hey would you like to yeah i
like riddles is that the game what did i
eat for breakfast i don't know eggs
but they don't bury survivors i don't
know how to handle this riddle
that's just a statement this is the guy
that's the guy from stuber
oh the guy from guardians of the galaxy
oh yeah that hit films the awful citizen
as he said how would it take for an
awful citizen did you mean to say lawful
citizen but look look awful scripts yeah
awful scripts awful wrestling
no you're absolutely right wow he's
awful we he this is the same guy who
doesn't need a gun to compensate yeah
okay well look what okay you don't why
do you need gen why do you need
generators right just twist family
robins in that [ __ ] do it yourself get
on a pedal right
why do you need this for power these are
tools just like firearms these are tools
to make your life safer to make your
life more efficient and i agree with you
you shouldn't be having a deal with a
bunch of bureaucratic red tape if it's
on your own property hey look you can
come over and join our side you just
can't decide when it's convenient for
you that my wife coming out of let's say
surgery in a wheelchair doesn't have the
right to have an assault rifle which by
the way would include the walther pdp
with over 10 round magazines well yeah
it would be illegal because the magazine
ban so let's just let's just be consider
let's just be consistent about it awful
citizen
i don't think you should have the
opportunity to continue firing at people
stephen after seven if you can't hit him
within seven yes then you know it's just
tough luck like they win don't be in a
movie with guns in it yeah well yeah no
no don't think only movies with guns
well that's it exclusively i'm not
saying you're the actual movie character
but you're kind of pro-gun all the time
on screen yeah there's no there's no
rom-com how to lose a batista in 10 days
so it's pretty easy just cut off his
testosterone supply like the bane mask
just
awful citizen can't handle lawful lawful
citizens lawful
the first ally's missing
i need help i need assistance with my
generator
what an ass i love where he draws the
line like the second amendment the thing
that can actually cause a society to
crumble australia yeah and he's like no
no it's all about power from the city
yeah yeah that gun buy back in australia
really yeah working like a charm
oh my gosh this is but this is how out
of touch these people are look i had
this i think it was on sky news where a
man said uh it was an ant gun i believe
it was kind of news it may have been bbc
you can probably
find it on youtube and by the way has
anyone noticed that youtube really
quickly have you noticed that youtube is
no longer an actual search engine i can
try and search for something specific
very specific like i was searching for a
very specific coffee maker the other day
for um a townhouse okay
and instead of that it showed all of
these videos from channels that i had
previously watched that may be coffee
related i couldn't find a review on the
coffee it used to like it is no longer
an actual search engine it's just an
algorithm it's just curated based on
what they think you want it is ceased to
fulfill its original purpose try it try
it comment in the section below let me
know search for something specific
search for like uh and i don't even mean
using me like steven crowder abortion
but search for i don't know uh pick an
appliance review yeah or like diet
something review pick something very
specific you will only find maybe two
videos google in general has it doesn't
work as a search engine it doesn't work
at a certain time like page two which is
what will happen is if you search for
chairs though you're gonna see ads for
months every website you go to it's just
gonna be like
would you like chairs chairs chairs
holding chairs well hopefully did you
see the christopher reeves one there's
another thing no it was like the google
page it was like christopher reeve's
birthday even though and it was like he
was blowing google not like that oh but
like a little following
that's the most offensive thing i've
ever seen so either someone is just so
incredibly tone deaf or they have the
best sense of humor yeah i couldn't
figure it out i'm like it's it's either
hilarious or they just have no idea what
they're doing the l is just a raising
stallion
[Music]
the first search no matter what you
search for is all the pretty horses
okay hey by the way you can follow us on
instagram or on tick tock where the chai
comes banned us but we have another
profile there now playing by the rules i
guess sneaky sneaky and uh you can hit
the notification bell if you want to
watch the show but the best way is just
tune in every monday through thursday
we're live 10 a.m even if it's a slow
news day we have a lot that we can talk
about have some fun with you yeah uh and
we'll take your chat of course later in
mud club and we're actually we didn't
have time for today we're going to read
in full on mug club this is this
write-up from a transgender comedian
beautiful and brave dahlia bell
criticizing dave chappelle's uh comedy
joke so we'll talk about dave chappelle
[Applause]
celebration i'm so proud
[Music]
i thought national coming out day was
thanksgiving
that's true i'm serious no that's now we
have columbus day as opposed to sorry
it's indigenous people
which by the way i should have done a
segment on this almost everything that
you believe about columbus is wrong now
i've talked about native americans i've
talked about how we actually tried to
buy manhattan how much we paid for
manhattan yeah the truth is
doesn't even like this but all the myths
about columbus kidnapping girls and
making them rape slaves
it's just not true and that's a good
example of what's been taught in our
schools when you look at contemporary
sources with christopher columbus look
no one's perfect but he's not the
monster he's been made out to be almost
everything you've read is incorrect and
it's written by people with an agenda
after columbus had lived and these
things are not objectively actually
checked for legitimacy so let me talk
about that tomorrow did you say
i'm sorry sure i'll go ahead and say i
do love the fact that we are celebrating
a man who got lost yes that is
his chief accomplishment is like
i've got a new way to get to india right
that way well that's what's hilarious is
they're called indians because he just
thought they were he's like ah this is
where i am it must be he's just trying
to cover
these are also indians yeah come on guys
they're everywhere you know a myth that
he was trying to prove the world wasn't
flat some people some people believe
that that's never true that's not true
you go all the way back to the greeks
they didn't believe that the world was
flat that's not why he did it johnny boy
is less than two percent now yeah johnny
boy's less than that
i don't know what that means about a
helicopter going up he says once he gets
the helicopter and he can do the
experiment he'll buy it well yeah a lot
of people looked in the sky and saw that
everything was round and agreed yeah
yeah yeah yeah except for the native
americans which i know who you herald
and praise you know herald and praise
yeah indigenous indigenous or
aboriginals in australia which is
offensive in north america can't do that
yeah that doesn't what do they call
black people in australia don't call
african americans
eskimos i don't know what they call them
african australians probably africans
are not in africa i don't think they
call them they're originally french i i
don't know i really don't know jews
unique canadians not that all right yes
they call them mondays yes
uh i don't know there are black people
there though yeah yeah but it's it's
more by choice though
right no i mean it was a penal column it
was a british penalty oh right yeah they
went over they sent
i forgot that they sent their prisoners
to paradise
maybe we ought to eat them yo kangaroo
let's send them to a warm weather and
beaches that'll teach you there's also
spiders and snakes and crocodiles and
sharks things yeah and those giant
spiders are not and like a dinner plate
yeah and everybody's okay with them no
way no they're like that's just our pet
winky you're like that's a giant spider
right yeah australians are crazy yeah
and the brazilian wandering spider can
but i've talked i've talked about it too
much
spider can bite you causing priapism
until death for those who don't know yes
priapism is a raging erection so people
like when they say why are you afraid of
spiders well let me tell you why because
there's a spider that bites you in your
dick until it breaks and kills you no i
don't think well that's irrational
stephen it opens up in the inside of it
right
no it just oh they're actually using it
now the brazilian wandering spider we'll
bring this up on mud club for viagra for
like
yeah but it's brazilian it's not here
you're not there it's okay you could you
gotta get it from there because what
were they using before like no i'm not
talking about a pharmaceutical i'm
talking about his fear of a
brazilian they show up they travel in
banana baskets why don't you not be
afraid bananas
lumber every right to be afraid i have
every right to be afraid of wandering
spiders they're not small
big enough you know what the size matter
if it kills you by breaking your dick
yeah yeah it's just this is my people
that we've got it is absolutely true the
brazilian wandering spider and then
there's outside of sao paulo i've talked
about this snake island you guys wonder
what it is it's just an island of snakes
it's an island of snakes it's something
like nine snakes per square meter just
exists as an island and the only reason
we can't destroy snake island i'm sorry
i'm getting off on a tangent here i've
talked about this before but it really
bothers me i have nightmares about this
stuff is because well there's some
endangered species that only they're
endangered species that only exist on
snake island if we destroy them wait a
second we're not destroying snake island
because we might disrupt the ecosystem
of snakes who live exclusively on snake
island kill them all immediately
firebomb
this is why i've said burn down the
rainforest yes
i don't give a rat's ass will you
replace for the robin williams bat and
fern gully right burn it down yeah no
but you're right snake island not cool
no i i've seen video footage and it's
like i don't even know how the cameras
got there they have flying snakes i know
they jump up it's a horrible place
not everything should be alive no we
should start a gofundme to destroy snake
island i do it i'm with you they're
always like well you know it destroys
their natural ecosystem which i don't
really buy when they talk about like
sharks like oh they're an apex predator
so then we'll have too many seals you
think people will be missing it like on
their surfboard remember back back in
the good old days of great whites when
we used to go out here and miss half a
hammy on the way back in no now it's
just seals okay maybe it smells kind of
funny but the point is the eco life uh
finds a way in this case you have a
closed ecosystem it's snake island
you're disrupting
nothing outside of snake island burn it
make it painful make it so painful make
it so brutal that all other snakes look
geez we were even thinking about just
like a vacation home i think we're going
to stay away yeah
yeah i want it to hurt i want her so
badly a snake never considers a time
shift exactly i wanted to be like oh
i i don't want to be no snake no i don't
want to be a snake island okay speaking
of snakes grow some jacqueline moore
now
jacqueline moore of netflix uh she's the
sh
okay sorry jaclyn moore no it's not for
you because i was almost messed up my
pronouns oh geez so dave chappelle let's
get the stinger again i'll hit it again
no no no no no no no no no no so we
talked about this last week
[Laughter]
it's something beautiful
which i'm proud
yes
and someone did in the back of the uber
this
i was like what's that was that blitzen
okay
all right okay so look let me so dave
chappelle we talked about this last week
we had not watched the special did you
watch the special i did yeah okay so i
watched the special too pretty good
special i would say not his best not as
worse but pretty damn good yeah and i i
came out i really like the coming out
swinging and i guess we can talk later
about it but it was a whole piece yes
and it was deliberately offensive in the
beginning to just almost like a pink
floyd album or like mars volta where
deal is at the comatorium where it's
like
it followed a theme right it was a whole
piece and i really i really respected it
yeah and after watching the special
and seeing the end of the special
my mind was blown that people well
it should have been blown that people
were
unbelievably just grossly
misrepresenting the special and what
dave chappelle did and said and we'll
show you the ending to it because the
whole ending is a very
pro-lgbt message a pro-empathy message
while still maintaining pro free speech
but he has a very touching end to it
where some people are left kind of
teary-eyed so this is something that now
i've had the luxury of watching all of
it um makes me even more disgusted with
jacqueline moore the showrunner of the
netflix program dear white people
wanted to boycott netflix and this has
been making the rounds right and there
even we'll read another article that
posted last night at the guardian uh in
an interview with variety more said i
have been thrown against a wall for
using a woman's bathroom i would just
say it's ironic that for somebody who
famously walked away from a tv show
because he felt like the messages of the
joke got lost he doesn't see what the
messages of these jokes do to people i'm
really tired of my existence being a
matter of debate this is something that
we all just have to get an opinion about
i am not going to be taking anything to
netflix for the time being i don't know
what it will take for me to feel
comfortable in changing that i know that
it will take some action so let's couple
things here let me guys let me go with
this um
this is what we're talking about when we
talk about when people mention cancel
culture you'll have some people and i
used to get bothered with bill bursting
you know there's like right there's like
two guys in the audience they get over
it right it's not about two guys in the
audience it's about some people in a
position of power who really don't
deserve to be in that position of power
amplifying their voice to try and take
away your livelihood it's about
comedians going and complaining to the
booker so you never get stage time we're
no one is arguing that these people are
the majority no one is arguing that by
the way a white straight male who
produces a show from the black american
point of view titled dear white people
who only transitioned more at december
2020 went from this
to this
right so it's a straight white male
canceling a black man no one is arguing
that that is the majority unfortunately
they are in positions of power to
dictate what you the majority get to
watch so when people say it's not a
thing it's accountability culture no
it's not
it's not it's people who get furious at
somebody for making a joke about
biological sex and then go to the most
powerful network in the world where they
happen to be a showrunner for i don't
know if it's popular but certainly one
of their uh hallmark shows dear white
people saying i am going to i'm not
going to do any work for you until you
fire this guy
for having a different point of view can
anyone imagine it going the other way
like ah you know what netflix if dave
chappelle said i'm not going to finish
my contract with you until you take away
the pro-transgender agenda pieces that
you push on kids i'm not going to give
you anything at netflix until you take
away girls uh uh twerking and booty
shorts how about that no you can never
imagine this going the other way well
the whole point really breaks down to
the dave was saying that the transgender
movement was more successful and easier
than the black movement in our society
right and look at what's happening as a
result of his special they're proving
his point no they're absolutely proving
his point and this is something that i
want to uh point out here and then i
have to let joe lewis out apparently he
heard a squirrel or something
um this is the part of chappelle's
special
that he ends with
and and i have to assume that people who
are boycotting him the white straight
male up until december 2020
still by the way bisexuals i
i don't know okay the point is
um
they saw a woman threw him against a
wall in a bathroom supposedly
within the last within the last six
months not buying that at all within the
last six months just nonsense no i just
it doesn't pass a sniff desk that and
poop swastikas and nooses at nascar uh
okay and no you shouldn't be in you're
almost always wrong
i think all swastikas are poopy yeah
exactly because that was something that
people believe is that neo-nazis who
actually believe and want to respect the
history of nazism would uh would
graffiti it in poop the only time i've
ever seen a neo-nazi was in higher
learning
at college yeah the movie oh college
michael rappaport i don't know i was
like you went to a community college
yeah well could have met one yeah she
was wearing looney tune shirts yes
wearing one of those wolf shirts from
the gas station
three of them howling so here is the
special uh here is the portion of the
special that these people who are
complaining undoubtedly saw and are
banking on you not watching here's the
context of how dave chappelle ended the
special but six days after that
wonderful night i described to you
my friend daphne
killed herself
oh yeah it's true story my heart was
broken
yeah it wasn't the jokes
i don't know if it was them dragging i
don't know what's going on in her life
but i bet dragging her didn't help
i was very angry at them i was very
angry at her
i felt like daphne lied to me she always
said she identified as a woman and then
one day she goes up to the roof of a
building and jumps off and kills herself
clearly
only a man would do some gangster [ __ ]
like that
hear me out
as hard as it is to hear a joke like
that i'm telling you right now daphne
would have loved that joke
that's why she was my friend
it's oval
[Music]
lbgtq lmnopqiz it is over
i am not telling another joke about you
until we are both sure that we are
laughing together
i'm telling you this done i'm done
talking about it
all i ask from your community
with all humility will you
please
stop
punching down on my people thank you
very much
and good night
[Applause]
okay
now whether you feel that that does not
erase the misdeeds of the previous
comments in his special jokes
it's proactive to avoid
and to not tell people about that
context when people say taken out of
context sometimes it becomes sort of
just a dodging right of responsibility
but here's the thing
if you tell someone for example we'll
get to it a little bit where people talk
about tom sawyer huckleberry finn
if you've read a book
and you tell someone this book is
horrible because you read them some
horrible portion from chapter four
but you know that there's redemption in
chapter 10
and you specifically don't tell people
about chapter 10 you are lying about
that book you are now a propagandist
that's what this is at netflix it is
propaganda the person knew what happened
at minute 5 6 16 knows what happened at
minute 55 and specifically omits it
guess what there are a lot of people out
there like me last week because i have
twins right we have people here with the
covet don't worry they're all fine i
repeat myself they're just staying home
so they're not contagious but i didn't
have time to watch the special but i
said ah i'm willing to bet that there's
some bs i'm gonna watch the special and
i watch it and i go oh okay of course
i've been lied to does that comment
below does that change your opinion does
that change your opinion that's even if
you're pro lgbt does that change your
opinion if you think that dave chappelle
went too far or if you thought he was
hateful or even if you thought it was
mean
that context matters yeah absolutely and
i love the way that he told that like i
i i'm not a comedian you guys know this
better than i do but it's a great way of
dealing with tragedy like sometimes it's
okay to just laugh about it and he said
it like daphne would love that joke and
i didn't see a joke coming i thought he
was just gonna end like a really like
downtrodden like part of oh geez man he
just made everybody laugh and now
everybody's gasping right and then he
just turned it around that's why he's
one of the best i thought it was
fantastic yeah
and it's a great story it's about having
a friend who is transgender who he lets
open forum you know who essentially
bombs yeah and then somebody yells out
from the crowd as the carpet match the
drapes to attack her and she turns
around and says actually i have hardwood
floors and that makes everybody laugh
and it gives you an idea of this uh
woman's sense of humor as as well as his
yeah so
he builds this wonderful base of how he
has a relationship with another human
being outside of all the bs outside of
doing it just uh for posturing yeah this
is just a relationship he has with
somebody and he's also a black guy who's
you know known for being a reverend this
isn't probably the easiest thing to talk
about on stage no but he puts it out
there and he puts his life out there and
then he ends it in i think a really very
fascinating and beautiful way and
especially because he starts it's so
aggressive and that's why it's this
entire piece look so anything in this
piece though taken out of it i feel is
out of context no i completely agree
with you when people try to act as
though christians get you know what you
get from christians who by the way they
could tune into any comedy special
particularly catholics right they can
tune into any comedy special here joke
about priests or christians here jokes
about televangelists christians don't
try to get you banned and don't say that
we're going to boycott the world's
biggest multimedia producer i do them in
my act and they laugh right and at the
most you might get if it's really really
offensive you might get this
that's truly that's the sound my parents
make like when someone uses the lord's
name in vain in a movie
they don't need to write a letter right
well there was actually a couple of
people in the audience uh that were they
look i will i will not suppose before
them so we have this to pull up real
quick so all right let's throw this
picture up here is it in the audience
yes
[Laughter]
everybody is that trigglypuff and dame
edna yeah everybody around them is
laughing uh except for them everywhere
and you know they picked the front row
to be like we're going to show him our
turn face right trevor jack nicholson
when he had the tiny lipstick yeah
batman it looks like he got stuck by a
stingray
oh my wife and i watched it
we thought it was fantastic like all of
these all of his work that he was doing
was great so here's a point that you
just made a second ago the guy that's
trying to the girl that is trying to
cancel dave chappelle sorry screwed up i
i really didn't mean to i will hit it
again in in december 2020 could not have
done it of course no there was no way
that at that time a straight white male
like you said would have been able to
make these kinds of accusations against
dave chappelle a black man and try to
get him canceled but
the ultra privilege card which is the
whole point of dave's show he was
talking my question is how did this
straight white male become the show
runner of dear white people written from
the perspective of black people right he
had a very tiny dog yeah well this is
something i think is legitimate
grievance when black people say hey you
know the problem with a lot of the black
content out there is you don't really
have white writers writing for black
voices i'm like you know what that's a
legitimate yeah it makes sense if you're
going to create a show with largely a
black caster about black culture that
you should have a majority of your
writers be black and i don't think it
needs to be a pie chart exactly
representative of the demographics the
united states it makes sense no oh it
makes sense that let's say you're doing
family matters that should probably well
come on you think there's a white writer
on family who knows yeah fresh prince
that is sitting white writers
shaft should be written by my point is
just like james bond should be written
by a bunch of old british white guys who
you hate and it's okay because it's
totally safe to hate them all right mr
belvedere i believe was written by all
black people
by the way mr french all right there's
french involved
ah it really doesn't go the other way
though it doesn't go it's like oh
there's no black writers on elf there
was just a heroin addict yes
that's serious i'd have a punchline here
but the senior writer was nodding off
i guess i'll just eat another cat and
hope he comes too after his last dab of
smack
how many cat eating jokes could you fit
into a show before they were like you
know i think this means something else
yes this means
should we keep the cat facade up or
should i strap my arm down with the
surgical tubing and heat up the teaspoon
are you
oh by the way google the dad on that
show just see what yeah no i know
we're going to get to by the way same
tactics being used against tucker
carlson and you know yeah i've said
there are things that i disagree with on
tucker carlson about yeah of course i'm
not necessarily the biggest name but i
don't i don't dislike him and i will
defend anyone when i believe that
there's uh deliberately an attack in bad
faith they're doing the same thing but
before we get to that we are not above
making corrections on it so true we are
not and last week on um september 20 or
two weeks ago on september 29th i made a
mistake i i've always said call us on it
call us to the mat i made a mistake by
mixing up
kandahar i said kandahar when i meant to
say kabul now granted it's two cities
that start with k in a crappled country
however no excuses i will show you the
clip and we will correct it and you have
no idea if an airbase in the middle of
nowhere surrounded by landmines was an
effective stronghold that we should have
kept in lieu of trying to depart from
crowded kandahar one of the most crowded
cities i think the most crowded city in
afghanistan that had already been
overtaken by the taliban here's a
picture side by side so you can see the
bagram air base surrounded by landmines
kandahar
hard to tell i can't tell it's almost
like it would have been helpful to have
that second base who knows now again
this was just me miss speaking i said
kandahar i meant to say kabul but you
need to look as an audience i demand
that you in the comment section
you need to admonish me yes
okay well no not the comments let them
know that they need to admonish me
that's what's most important later on oh
no no just let them know they need to
admonish me
make it sting
i cannot get away with making these
kinds of mistakes
i'm just telling them again okay all
right i appreciate it what's next i mix
up kandahar and kabul
brian stelter with a picture of google
and twitter rotating chiron with
facebook no so look i need to pay the
price and we didn't know if i should rat
you know uh have the spiked garters to
ratchet down uh vlog myself um but we
did decide there needs to be some public
admonishment some public shaming helpful
uh so of course i i still have to i have
to host the show right you have to be in
this uh so um someone's gonna be uh
uh shamed punished in my uh tribute uh
even brendan
[Music]
which one of you is brendan
me
you've been selected for admonishment
what again
yeah
do i have to
yeah let's go
[Music]
good morning
yes
[Music]
all right even brendan uh and uh you can
come in here um there you go you do have
to admit that it was a it was a re it
was a really careless mistake yeah but
you were comparing u.s controlled
military air bases
yeah and and well kandahar is used by
the us and nato for military
so it's like well i don't i don't really
care so much i can't have that i can't
look i have the whole admonish setup
yeah some of them are day raiders we
can't let it go to waste i understand
what you're saying that they both had
military air bases but i was
specifically referencing kabul and some
people got you know about the population
density so you did get it wrong
i i mean i got it wrong yeah then you
you know you get punished because that's
in your contract so uh yeah everyone
monish
hmm yeah give some brendan's way too
let's skip more yeah okay
yeah it does stick all right you can get
going okay
severely admonished
[Applause]
well we have them uh we pay them for a
half day then they get double overtime
he was bleeding
well so the point is we're not going to
they're not going to stop they have to
be out there well that's true yeah we
have the back exit to leave first okay
yeah all right let's get to uh tucker
carlson uh rebuttal uh here a rebuttal a
lot to talk to carlson but fire tucker
carlson was trending right and um this
video comes from sorry it just trends so
often yes yeah exactly yeah again it
trends so often but you realize the
attacks are so lazy it's one of those
things it really is ad nauseam he's a
white supremacist enough that people
believe it
uh okay what we are going to do here is
show you the clips that were trending
top on twitter yesterday i believe
number one and then if you went to the
trend this was number one from the super
pac really american
i don't think he's a white supremacist i
just think he likes them a little more i
mean maybe he likes them a little more
we all have preferences it's national
coming out day
so they raised super pac really american
raised 1.8 million dollars during the
2020 election uh almost all of its money
is spent against republicans the entire
business model is it it's creating hit
pieces on notable republicans
conservatives right these things exist
sometimes they this is why let me be
really clear this is why i do this show
this is the only show that i'll ever do
because a lot of conservative media is a
bunch of non-profit people too and
people are beholden to that and it sucks
the only people were beholden to you
first off we're not funded by a
non-profit we're not funded by a foreign
caliphate like al jazeera we're quite
literally funded by you and we're not we
can't even say we get google funding so
do consider joining muggle
um but this is the portion of the clip
and i want to show you what they say and
then show you the exact clip that
they're referencing giving you context
kind of like with dave chappelle context
over content if that's nothing if
there's nothing else you leave with
today context over content i make it a
rule on this show that if we say
something that's something that could be
taken perceived as
all you need to do is extend it 30
seconds in either direction you'll say
oh okay well that's total that's totally
reasonable or i understand that that's a
joke that's generally the rule
um
he says in this video the guy from
really what is it really american what
is it really really amazing oh my gosh
that's just a really super really
american sounds like an old navy sale
yeah so really american says that uh
tucker carlson
is basically saying all of her problems
are from non-white people here you go
right tucker carlson just said this
there are no organized white supremacist
forces in this country okay there's two
ways to interpret that one is that white
people like me aren't quite as supreme
as advertising secret forces you can't
see but i don't think that's what tucker
meant white supremacist he's saying all
the trouble in america is because people
who aren't white don't know their place
remember that when they come for you oh
my god
for crying out loud i just had to beat
our number two employee here yeah for
saying kandahar instead of kabul i just
wish i could straw man this [ __ ] out of
everything i don't like and have no
accountability but you said it number
two who was number one i said it
it just said i'm gonna break a pool cue
you all can have triumphs basically
tucker girls said the white supremacists
are disorganized yeah no here's the
thing we have the full clip so if you
take the clip in context even out of it
look but yeah i know this this clip's so
short that he just strawman's what
parker carlson is saying is something we
do on the show i go
let's listen to what they say anytime i
do a john oliver rebuttal i say go and
watch the whole video yeah even though
it's against my best it's against my
vested interest for you to support that
content on youtube so that it auto plays
him or god forbid seth meyers after this
show still don't know how that's
happening but
full context tucker carlson was
discussing mask mandates and
specifically rebutting a claim you tell
me with this full clip if tucker carlson
is saying white people are better than
brown people what used to be called
legitimate civic disagreement
is now a threat to the nation
is this really about people being upset
about mask mandates or are there sort of
underlying disruptive forces white
nationalists uh anarchists whatever in
this country that are using mass
mandates and a public health crisis to
sort of wage chaos
get that more on off television that's
hurting the country i mean come on now
they're racist now
they're racist because they don't want
their kids to be masked
imagine saying something like that
there are underlying forces at work
secret forces you can't see
must be q anon or white supremacists
there are no organized white supremacist
forces in this country we have a lot of
problems that's not one of them
ah that's clearly him saying all of our
problems are from brown people or from
non-white people that don't know their
place this is that's what i am this is
something that it's not just what's
being done the lie
look the in not only in the intent but
what these people are estimating the
outcome will be when they take clips so
out of context yeah when they take that
clip and they say
uh tucker carlson made a white
supremacist comment saying that white
people are better than look
they're expecting you to not watch the
full clip in context people at really
american people at msnbc they believe
you're stupid people
because only a stupid person would
believe that if they watch the clip in
context they believe that you are
fundamentally stupid people and that's
why stupid people like you out there
shouldn't have the right to communicate
information on social media shouldn't
have the right to forward emails
shouldn't have the right to express your
opinion because you're too stupid they
understand what tucker carlson is
actually saying that he supports white
supremacists let's go on to the next
clip from really american
well how about just real quick it's been
over two years people are tired of masks
yeah i just leave it at that right
exactly that's exactly it and he went on
to make that point too but they were
saying what are the other reasons with
mask mandates well you know what we have
a man on the street coming up pretty
soon where i interviewed a bunch of
privileged white people yeah in an area
of town and then interview black people
guess who opposed mass mandates more
guess who opposed vaccine man names more
don't worry don't worry don't worry
stupid black people msnbc will speak for
you don't worry dumb african-americans
says really american we will speak for
you when tucker carlson says
mask mandates
having a strong disapproval rating is
not because of race it's it's really
because you're stupid and i know that
many of you black people out there are
actually opposed to the vaccine mandates
and mask mandates you're stupid let me
educate you that's what they are saying
and i know someone's going to try and
take that out of the contest and say
stephen said stupid black people i'm
saying they are saying stupid black
people because there's a significantly
higher percentage of black americans who
are mistrustful of government then
certainly the mostly privileged white
people who run really american or msnbc
here's another thing that they uh they
said again this was trending on twitter
didn't see a fact check
when black people protest it's a riot
when white people protest its democracy
he makes this this is another straw man
taking things out of context here you go
when black people protest it's a riot
the antifa domestic terror movement when
white people protest it's democracy
okay he said antifa yeah a couple of
things here um
it's the wrong organization even as
absurd as that is the guy with the corn
haircut yelling john favreau and pcu yes
yes it is he took one clip of someone
yelling by the way who waited their turn
to get up and spew we're going to show
the clip just so you know so i can show
you the worst that's happened at these
municipal meetings by the way what
you're about to see is the worst thing
that has happened
and contrast that of course with uh
billions of dollars in damages with
thousands of arrests and hundreds of
casualties with black lives matter and
ant for riots uh but here you go what he
is trying to say is uh when black people
protest it's a riot when white people
protest its democracy here's the
weirdest strongest argument they could
pull is this i'll never relinquish it do
you think that the four feet of marble
that holds you above high in this
chamber will help you from the fate of
humanity which you are unleashing
wwe
it won't
your children and your children's
children will be subjugated they will be
asked how many vaccines have you had
have you been a good little nazi
hello
when does alex take his wig off yeah
disguises i like it oh man
it's not the delivery i would have used
but you know what
hey not wrong no he's not wrong on what
he said and he's sitting there just the
fact that he's sitting at a desk and
leaning into a microphone means he's
respecting that he's supposed to be at
that spot at that microphone he's not
burning down a walgreens no and he's
also not threatening the lives of them
he basically said you are unleashing
force forces that you cannot hope to
control once they're out and your kids
will pay the price that's exactly what
he was saying he was saying it very
loudly i'm coming for you with reds for
days but still they they'd burn down
seattle nobody thought it was all black
people right yeah no he said antibodies
i think antifa i think white yes
generally speaking
we ran into some antique people who were
black
majority but
can anyone anyone any this is an actual
challenge anyone show me any incident
for example of a parent right now right
running in a mass shooting
at a pta meeting at a municipal board
meeting i know they've said shame on you
shame on you you're trying to subjugate
us i know that's gotten heated i know
that people have yelled but guess what
here's the thing the argument that
really american is making
is actually correct it's true when there
are riots in the streets the black lives
matter protests again we're talking
about i think
close to a thousand officer casualties
when you're talking about injuries and
you're talking about also deaths
including officer david dorn four people
shot in shaz you're talking about two
billion dollars worth of damages talking
about thousands of arrests that is a
riot when people get up and yell at a
town hall or a municipal meeting even if
they're yelling
that is democracy
you may not the point is what this guy
they're tipping their hand do you see
really american is tipping their hand
saying see we don't like what they're
saying even if they wait their turn even
if they're peaceful if we don't like
what they're saying
shut them down they're not even arguing
that parents out there are violent do
you know how i know look right now let's
look at the fbi and doj uh and what
they're doing right now they're going to
investigate parents yeah
this is school board pardon my language
okay if you have kids right there this
is
[ __ ]
terrifying it is evil and all of this
was shoehorned in under the guise of the
patriot act a long time ago where and i
understood it at the time my mistake
now i wasn't even old enough to vote for
george bush at this point
that being said i thought okay i
understand because we're facing
terrorism but you know what libertarians
and conservatives and people who opposed
it were right because now what was
originally designed to be used right to
secure us from foreign threats to spy on
foreign threats is now being used
internally to investigate and to monitor
americans at an
unprecedented level
in unprecedent this is what's important
when people say well democrats didn't
oppose the debt ceiling being raised
under trump trump spent some money
you're absolutely right and on this show
we weren't big fans of the 1.5 trillion
bill and we were talking about the covid
pandemic we thought listen we just have
to march our way through it but do you
really want to compare that to what do
we know six seven trillion dollars in
the first six months the scale is
different sure americans have had to be
patted down at the tsa or go through
those nudie x-ray machines which we all
oppose but the level with which th the
pernicious nature of this government
using what we're designed to be tools
and times of war simply to investigate
and intimidate political dissidence by
admission
no one said that they're violent right
now no at these meetings
let's flip that really quickly actual
domestic terrorists uh antifa and black
lives matter who killed people yes
killed people who commit billions of
dollars in damages
merit garland
right i think we have a montage clip
what did he say when asked if they were
investigating these people we look at
antifa as more of an ideology or a
movement
than an organization do you regard
assaults on federal courthouses or other
federal property as acts of domestic
extremism domestic terrorism so an
attack on a a
courthouse while in operation plainly is
um domestic
extremism um
terrorism
domestic terrorism an attack simply on a
government property at night or any
other kind of circumstances is a clear
crime and a serious one and should be
punished both are uh criminal
um but one is uh a core attack on our
democratic institutions oh okay so like
burning down a courthouse normally they
said yeah yeah insurrection look an
insurrect let's be clear insurrection
requires a plan to overthrow the
government right not like ah i had a few
oh duels and i'm here taking a blow
that's a non-alcoholic right give me the
fighter's thing or sure what the hell's
the difference the point is when you
talk about an insurrection requires a
plan yeah and an instruction can happen
at a national level it can happen at a
federal level it can happen at a local
level what about burning down a
courthouse what about firebombing a
police precinct is that not considered
insurrection yeah what about hey when we
talk about domestic extremism which by
we're talking about terrorism terrorism
is violence as a means to an end to
subjugate and implement a point of view
do you think that are you a trump
supporter we've got a trump supporter
here bam bam to the face like travis
bickle do you think that that might be
domestic terrorism that happened in chaz
top seattle not a peep no not a peep at
all and i love how he pivots away from
this he's like well if the courthouse
wasn't you know in use i mean they
waited until 501 yeah i think it was
fine but here's what he didn't say
police stations were burned with police
officers still there right merrick talk
to me about that because every single
time this came up it was the peaceful
protest part that they showed right like
look i don't have a problem with people
protesting if you go out on the highway
and get by a car sorry i'm not going to
feel super sorry for you but when you
start to attack police officers looting
nike burning walgreens and burger king
and courthouses that's different i don't
have a problem with you marching in the
street i have a problem with you that
the entire precinct the officers left
the building looking like dark man
that's my primary problem you turned him
into a sam raimi film with no
no consideration for what happens to her
so now let's contrast that merrick
garland
urging the fbi to mobilize against
parents protests
saying reading it in recent months
there's been a disturbing spike in
harassment intimidation and threats of
violence against school board
administrators board members teachers
and staff so when you combine all that
harassment intimidating intimidation and
threats of violence
makes me think it's [ __ ] here's why
yeah when i've actually had real death
threats and i've had to be on the phone
with with uh
law enforcement officials let's put it
that way i never i never said like well
i get harassed i get bullied oh and by
the way here's someone who threatened to
kill my wife and send a picture of her
to work you know i didn't do that i was
that's that was kind of you know i
didn't bury the lead yeah
that's how i know it's [ __ ] when
people go i get bullied okay all right
check my twitter replies check the
comment section when there are
legitimate threats and i get them all
the time they are sent and i go this is
a legitimate threat this is what i'm
afraid of saying there's harassment and
bullying in the threats of violence oh
wait what threats of violence well you
know it's kind of like they don't
they're going to do they do all the
things they say you've heard about the
harassment part i'm asking about the
threats of violence and are they
credible dave you can get your he david
just had to go get a small block so
again this is the same guy who didn't
have an answer when we're talking about
anthony black lives matter he wrote in
the coming days the department will
announce a series of measures designed
to address the rise in criminal conduct
directed towards school personnel anyone
have a rap sheet we've made our rap
sheet available again all references all
sources are available at
lotterycredit.com with a link in the
description we have a long rap sheet
with black lives matter and antifa
where's the rap sheet for these parents
we got the guy wearing a corn guitarist
haircut
post 2004 well i mean i think what he is
saying he's so loosely defining what
he's going after it's people being held
accountable on school boards for what
they're doing to these people's children
yeah you don't like that i get it resign
and let me get through this here because
i have the pta meeting
yeah exactly yeah good point what's
there for like so everyone good teaching
uh teaching boys about chicks with dicks
and that boo radley was a racist looks
like my work is done here yeah but we
have questions we disagree work is done
yeah it's time for my edibles
do i need to call the fbi
exactly uh let's suck at the phone yeah
it's right it's the jitterbug that just
kills them
i am directing the fbi working with each
u.s attorney to convene meetings with
federal state local and tribal leaders
got to include them tribal leaders
they're surprised at that letter what
apparently schools that aren't on their
hosting parent teacher or so why didn't
we think of that
you rolled an eight that's time to pay
up yes
when i hear from the mother of a buffalo
soldier yes
justin hoffman stop sleeping in our
teepees so yeah
uh convened meetings with federal state
local and tribal leaders facilitate the
discussion and strategies for addressing
threats against school administrators
board members teachers and staff and
will open dedicated lines for threat
reporting assessment and response and of
course this was spurred by the national
school board association asking
protesters to be deemed domestic
terrorists by the way this is the same
association especially when you look at
the control of unions in education who
have much harsher restrictions
here than in places like europe when it
comes to masks because in europe in
places like norway in places like the uk
they have said well there's no signs for
masks in children in schools and we
don't think that it's worth it and it's
actually very there is harm for children
that's what they've said with
governments in europe the united states
is being more stringent about this and
keep in mind that this national
association said we're not going to uh
go back to class until and then insert
whatever right yeah well because three
months vacation out of here
no no no it's not enough for the real
heroes no no no absolutely not and by
the way they wrote that they wrote that
letter to the white house and within a
week merrick garland comes out with his
thing saying we're going to get the fbi
involved and they said they they threw
in the catch line for everything they
wanted domestic terrorism and hate
speech they think they said specifically
they said we think that it rises
potentially maybe to this level and i'm
like hate speech oh there's the word
that we can't define oh he said it he
said it again
exactly
the hate speech that's inappropriate
speech that could be uh considered a
terrorist threat by the way we're going
to show you some clips could literally
be repeating the curriculum back to them
i warn you if you have kids right now i
always say this isn't a trigger warning
i just don't want kids watching
something unfortunately they're teaching
it in schools yeah their parents
protesting pornographic material racist
material and if they try and read it at
the pta they try and shut them down and
say it's inappropriate so keep that in
mind repeating the words that your
teachers deliver to your children when
they have authority of them and you are
not able to defend your child
is considered a terrorist threat let's
be clear about that they have your kids
for eight hours a day and this is the
kind of [ __ ] that they're teaching them
i am surprised that more parents aren't
livid let's start off lightly so here's
some examples critical race theory
people try and say oh it's a boogeyman
no it's not it's a real thing it's uh it
was just mandated by gavin newsom
uh california under the disguise of uh
ethnic studies but of course it talks
about racial superiority and hierarchy
and things like white privilege okay
yeah uh last year california teachers
and the education organizations released
a toolkit called
a pathway
to equitable math instruction huh yeah
it's called two plus two equals four
divided up by four you each get one shut
up and do your test
what do you just make it harder for the
asians like just make their math work
seriously the tool kit is described as
resources and guidance to support black
latinx and multilingual students to
thrive in grades six through eight yeah
by the way do you know how i know that
this is [ __ ] latinx is in there time
and time again we had our we went out we
asked people there has been empirical
data that shows that latin americans
that latino americans hispanic americans
find the term offensive you stupid white
[ __ ] they don't like it that's how you
know this is bull crap yeah exactly well
if their plan is anything like what's
going on in san francisco where they
actually decouple this tracking they're
like oh hey you guys that are really
good at math and you would be in
advanced placement well that's racist
now so we're gonna have to put you back
in the other class with everybody else
oh by the way that's something that is
happening in san francisco we weren't
planning on talking about it i being
raised in high school i was no longer in
bilingual education because i was raised
you know they thought i was learning
disabled until fourth grade so i speak
french pretty well my mom's french i
learned how to read and write french
first but
i realized that colleges look at your
transcripts yeah they don't look at the
actual level of course load like if you
have advanced french and stuff no idea i
never wanted to be an advanced french
right they kept one well because i
figured i could get like a 96 in normal
french and i'd probably be you know i'd
be running a 60 or 70 and advance french
so
they used to have this is like an asian
with math yes
i swear i swear this is true we used to
have something at centennial regional
high school people out there you can let
me know maybe it's a thing across quebec
called reppin june which is actually a
good idea which is if you fail a subject
throughout the year
you had two weeks and it was like summer
school you had two weeks where you could
do a concentrated course take the test
again it was a provincial test yeah and
if you test if you beat the test
whatever your grade was i don't remember
the threshold then you could actually
continue and not be held back but people
who didn't fail anything you had uh what
you would have is like baseball or you'd
have home economic you get to do a bunch
of fun stuff yeah unfortunately if you
had scored too highly in the regular
level subjects throughout the year
instead of getting to pick wiffle ball
golf which i did i got put for two weeks
in june an advanced french class and i
told and i just was screwing around
i was like i don't want to do this and i
remember her name wasn't the device
she's like i don't know why you're doing
this there's so much potential i'm like
i don't want potential i don't want any
potential i just want to get a free
grade that's really easy where i do just
write basic verb tenses i don't want to
be an advanced friend she's like well
just make the most of it i didn't show
up i pulled off my french teacher's wig
i went down to the office i said i am
not going to do this i will not be in
advance french i'm not that smart but in
bobo french which is what we called it i
am a genius and i want it to stay that
way lo and behold
come eighth grade advanced french i
never made honor roll again
i love how you had that you were trying
to dumb it down you were basically
trying to do what san francisco is
forcing everybody to do that that's the
whole point colleges don't go like oh he
wasn't advent they don't care they do
care about advancement no for crying out
loud
you they don't my brother went to ut
yeah and they didn't even know what to
do with the system because it only goes
to 11th grade and you have seizures
after like ah we'll just let's come in
you know what they just said we'll just
make you a sophomore so in other words
if i don't even understand what the do
you think they're going to look and be
like oh you're french is french 401 not
french 402. they have no idea that's
true they just go you got a 95 in french
oh we should put you in the
international program you can be part of
the student
u.n my point is my point is act it up to
get out of it just aim to be really good
when compared to mediocrity well that's
though they're doing it for you you
won't even have to aim for that anymore
so okay back to san francisco the
toolkit consists of five strides on the
path to math equity stride one is
dismantling racism in mathematics
instruction i always thought the cosine
tangent seemed a little like a pointed
hat its first chapter includes a section
on dismantling white supremacy in math
classrooms oh good some of the listed
ways the whites are the supreme supreme
people at math yeah what are you adding
up k's to three
it's strikeouts in baseball okay
three this sign is wrong
why is
why are you putting advanced students
into classes with students that are
awful and don't want to be there yeah i
don't know for the same reason they're
putting them in white supremacy math
you'll just you'll just
obliterate the curve any chance that
right
i remember when i did join my local
neo-nazi chapter the flashing hand
signal it was basically just
multiplication cards so oh i was like i
don't know my sevens did they make you
chug a liter of water
i had to say fire hose amazing so uh
some of the listed ways that math
perpetuates white supremacy this is from
equitablemath.org so you know what's
official the focus on getting the right
answer that that's wrong that
perpetuates what's worse
what students are being tracked
wait what what these are these are
examples focus on getting the right
answer yes students are required to show
their work grading practices are focused
on lack of knowledge so look i wanted to
make sure i heard you right before i i
went home and ended this yes
yes you and the show runner for netflix
because of dave chappelle's tawdry jokes
look
look
this is racist it's saying that getting
the right answer in math class is white
supremacy
you are
so racist not even kind of racist you
are the problem again what are they
saying you stupid black people yeah you
can't be expected to get the right
answer in math we shouldn't expect you
to show your work
math should not that's a construct of
white supremacy
don't worry don't worry i guarantee if
you ask black people hey two plus two
equals what four do you think that you
should get graded on being correct on
that yeah this guy gets it wrong should
he get it wrong yeah well a bunch of
rich white [ __ ] say that that's
racist
they're not going to be on board with
this this isn't coming from black
americans i'm not saying i speak for
black americans but neither do you
equitablemath.org i guarantee it outside
of getting the answer right which god i
hope is the right thing for engineers
when they're kind of designing the
airplane i want the math to work out on
that in bridges but also
showing your work those are the two most
important things in mathematics
otherwise you don't need it you really
shouldn't teach it because showing your
work makes you work through a problem it
makes you find out where you're making a
mistake and it makes you be diligent
that's why asians are better at math
it's not because they're just gifted at
math they will work on a problem longer
than other people groups well also it's
because of linguistics if you look at
the asian language and mathematics not
only that but also their primary crop
rice is very persnickety so it requires
a very scientific approach you've read
malcolm gladwell haven't you well i've
read a lot about this and i know he
writes about it but it is true there's
there are cultural reasons and of course
it's very highly prized in asian
american households right apparently
this is racist like hey guess what i
can't say that asians are good at math
blacks are good at jazz
i was wrong i wish who's the
asian-american coal train equivalent i
know someone's gonna yo-yo ma i mean i
don't know well i know i wish i would
have gone to school now i would have
graduated with honor yeah i was like
what did you learn nothing i got nothing
right
you can't prove it dave just brought up
a great point you show your work and say
that everything's racist you'll get an a
you just put all the gifted and talented
people in the class where they're going
to get beat up for the right test oh my
gosh do you have any idea how easy it
would be for me to [ __ ] my way
through this class that's why i never
got below an a plus on humanities
they're going to be doing bookkeeping
for other students and drug runners
my trigonometry would have just been
writing down well actually if you
understand trigonometry and its roots in
white supremacy most black americans
weren't allowed to own property
therefore they wouldn't need to figure
out the size of their triangular lot
which is perfectly shaped break yourself
so actually i think and they'd be like a
plus right exactly i believe it uh it's
uh triga nomatri
how bored these guys are going to be in
class like they're used to like solving
very complex theoretical math problems
and you're going to put them in algebra
what
that's exactly my point thank you okay
my eyes glazed over okay so look this is
the this is the bull crap with things
like math where you think that they
shouldn't be involving any of the
humanities
but this past month in fairfax virginia
again the fbi doj wants to investigate
you for this if you're mad about that if
you think all of us right now as parents
if we were dumb enough to put our kids
in public school right no we'd show up
and be mad they would say you're you're
potentially domestic terrorists for
saying the right answer is the right
answer in math but there's more to it
fairfax virginia this past month watch
how they react when hearing their own
curriculum read back to them parents
protested and i warned you if you have
kids here uh though we've bleeped it i
think we've caught everything uh they
protested pornographic school books
there at the uh at the library here you
go after seeing a september ninth school
meeting in texas on pornography in the
schools i decided to check the titles at
my child's school both of these books
include pedophilia
sex between men and boys scout's manual
both books describe different acts one
book describes a fourth grade boy
performing oral sex on an adult male
from the author maya kobabe
stephen
i can't wait to have your [ __ ] in my
mouth
i am going to give you the job of your
life and then i want you inside me end
quote
from the author jonathan everson
what if i told you i touched another
guy's
what if i told you i sucked it i was 10
years old but it's true i sucked doug
goebbels the real estate guy and he
sucked mine too
this is not an oversight at fairfax
virginia law makes the possession the
red smash of courage an exhibition of
obscene material and child pornography a
felony crime
every day you allow such books to be on
your schools makes you complicit in
furthering potential violations of the
law
finally the plan talks about promoting
parent participation and i agree you're
pushing on kids
her son
showed her a reading assignment given to
him by his fairfax community reading
school it said this is quote
all in their 20s
minus women [ __ ] cows dreaming of
rape sir waiting for these are a part of
a reader's center that your school
assigned we have children in the world
oh so it's only okay to teach that to
children when parents aren't in the room
got it read the trash but you refuse
the virginia department of transport of
education refused when people act like
this is domestic terrorism have you ever
watched the brits in parliament do you
have any idea what our founding fathers
did when they were arguing to call
someone a fool was way worse than to
call them a i can't even say whatever
you can't say it's about as bad as it
gets you want to accuse these people of
being domestic terrorists because
they're reading your reading assignments
out loud and this is what's really
important they want to operate in the
dark always no no we want to assign this
to your children we want to read this to
your children you can't read it back to
us when there are other eyes on us we
want to do it when we have your children
for eight hours completely unsupervised
nothing could possibly go wrong there
and by the way let's compare this and i
know i'm not a fan of book banning i
don't think saying that this shouldn't
be a reading assignment or effectively
pedophile pornography shouldn't be in
the library but um let's compare this to
books that the left
wants to actively ban
the adventures of huckleberry finn and
to kill a mockingbird are banned from
accomac county public schools last month
a parent expressed concerns over the
book's use of the n-word but there's so
much racial
slurs in there and
offensive wording that you can't get
past that and
right now we are a nation divided as it
is she filed a request to have the
district find alternatives forcing them
to temporarily suspend use of the two
novels the n-word shouldn't even be in a
book teresa wilkins hopes the district
bans them yeah i'm going to take advice
yeah you seem like a reader so that they
are
able to say that to anybody but some
people disagree saying even though the
books have racial slurs the quality
there's even one person who uh said oh
the white saviorism of uh to kill a
mockingbird the n-word shouldn't be in a
bro book well you're not going to love
ice-t's new trigonometry curriculum
because it's riddled with it
um well if he had had a black lawyer and
to kill a mockingbird it would have
ended much differently
exactly it's like contextually you have
parents domestic terrorists sorry who
are complaining about pornographic
material and factually incorrect
material as it relates to math in order
to systematically uh of course try and
brainwash students into
believing in racial division into
stoking racial division right into uh
identity politics you have parents
saying i don't think i should i don't
think that my kids should have to read
about bestiality or about second dick in
the library i think that that is wrong
and they're speaking they're waiting
their time whereas on the left they say
again this is context above content the
n-word
is in huckleberry finn hmm
what's the context there yeah is it
about people being the same
and is it about people uh coming
together and becoming friends
huckleberry finn and time sorry what
about to kill a mockingbird that's right
the n-word is used is it used by the
villains
is it used by the villains to denigrate
the innocent man who's on trial who is
being defended by a white attorney
regardless of during a racially divided
time
he fails to see someone exclusively by
the color of their skin that content is
that overall a positive message against
racism
well look i think you have a point here
i would be fine if critical race theory
would take that out too because it
probably says something about people
saying the n word and that being bad
right right i mean that's the whole
foundation of it so we can't have that
either and by the way i know that that
mom is probably very diligent she is
doing all of her work at home to make
sure that those songs are being sung by
famous
rappers that have that word because lest
they think they can say it like she said
they'll think that they can say that
word in general conversation no
absolutely and i think even more
importantly in that first clip did you
see how ugly that couple was in the
first row if you go back that is a very
hideous couple they were just being
titillated by what the lady was reading
i don't even think they have kids i
think they were applauding they were
like oh this is though this is bad yeah
what i i'm just even wondering what
books these were though in school like
who like did the teacher write them he's
like this is my literature uh take it
home and read we would like to present
your uh your assistant professor this
year bill cosby so you're gonna be down
there about this in the library wake up
with porn bugs this is my book they were
asking for it by dr bill cosby yeah we
asked kevin spacey to come in and teach
ninth grade
this this is my book to fizz the
mockingbird
so look this is my point here is this is
really scary this is unprecedented and
if you look at them labeling you the fbi
doj this is why amer don't blame
americans we're going to go to mugler a
little bit and read this letter here to
dave chappelle
don't blame americans people in the
media people of course in government but
i repeat myself right now elites don't
blame americans for no longer trusting
your institutions
when the institutions of education are
obviously no longer of any value and
then the institutions of our
intelligence agencies once actually
generally seen as the good guys have
decided to selectively enforce the law
and investigate one group of non-violent
offenders who are concerned parents
waiting their turn to get up at
municipal meetings
labeling them as domestic terrorists
don't get mad when those parents don't
trust the fbi or the doj don't get mad
when those parents don't trust the most
secure and safe election of all time
because it's being parroted by the media
who by the way have been silent about
these stories don't get mad at americans
for no longer trusting these
institutions when you have decided to
subvert them and then use them for
political gain don't act like people
have politicized kovid
you did it first don't act like people
have politicized education you did it
first don't act like people have
politicized the fbi and doj you've done
it first don't act like people are
politicizing the media and there was
some bygone era of journalism and walter
cronkite and dan rather it never existed
you committed this in first and this is
people reacting to it the good thing is
you can count on conservatives you can
count on right-wingers reacting in a way
that is orderly and in accordance with
the constitution but something you don't
like to hear if you keep investigating
them and arresting them and holding them
in jail without trial the constitution
has corrections for that too don't
overreach and then blame it on the
people who react to you overreaching
it's got to stop we are headed off a
cliff and we're not headed off a cliff
because of both sides we're not we're
headed off a cliff because these
institutions have decided that instead
of keeping america safe they want to
utilize them to destroy one half of
america and one half of america at some
point isn't gonna have it all right
we'll talk more about it uh youtube you
know what you can piss off
so